un rassemblement de soutien était
programmée devant le commissariat de
besançon il a été annulé après la levée
des gardes à vue des six personnes
arrêtées hier à l'issue de la
manifestation un groupe se dirige vers
la city et la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie où se déroule une réunion
entre plusieurs élus comme le montrent
ces images amateurs
l'ambiance entre policiers et
manifestants est pacifique mais six
d'entre eux sont arrêtés dont une
mineure et frédéric guillaume figure
emblématique du gilet jaune
il ya un petit hic inc elle durer deux
trois minutes
s'était amusé à michel ans les policiers
étaient déjà postés
ils ont fait une sommation dans la
minute qui a suivi ça a été ça a été un
assaut il y avait une soixantaine de
fonctionnaires qui était qui était
présent sur le terrain face à une
trentaine ou une quarantaine de
manifestants pacifiques et surtout ça a
été une charge ininterrompue les
organisations syndicales qui ont eu vent
de ces arrestations dénonce
l'acharnement des policiers sur le monde
militant on a pu le voir j'ai besoin
sont déjà à peu près deux ans avec la
sphère qui a vu à la fac avec déjà les
personnels a fait qu'inviter mis en
garde à vue et poursuivie pénalement par
simplement avait fait naître région le
conseil d'administration et on voit
aussi le monde syndical aussi et les
gens qui se battent sli gilet jaune qui
jamais eu autant de répression une
accusation que récuse fermement le
commissaire divisionnaire
il n'y a pas eu d'actes de violence
aucun usage de matraques
nous avons juste arrêter des personnes
qui ne sont plus dans un cadre légal de
manifestation et qui commettent un délit
en bloquant le tram le bus et la
circulation sur la voie publique
sur les six personnes relâchées deux
font l'objet de compensations pénale
frédéric guillaume lui sera convoqué en
mars devant le tribunal correctionnel de
besançon dans un communiqué
l'intersyndicale demandent l'abandon des
poursuites pénales